so we've covered one side of the liz
cheney fiasco
which is republicans have stripped
republican congresswoman liz chaney from
her leadership role because she admits
joe biden won the election
and trump is lying when he says that he
won and he should stop
that's the one side now on the other
side
of that is that liz cheney was replaced
by someone and that someone is
republican congresswoman elise stefanik
who now becomes republican conference
chair after liz cheney's removal
the pro-trump right wing is going
absolutely crazy about elisa fanuc they
just love her
and sadly elise stefanik is sort of a
better spoken marjorie taylor green or
lauren bober she's just as nutty don't
be confused
she just knows how to better present her
ideas
to appear less outrageous and case in
point
she gets herself a congratulatory pat on
the back interview
on fox news this weekend conducted by
none other than trump suck up maria
bartoromo and right away
it goes to the big lie about the
election being stolen and again
stefanik doesn't indicate that her
opinion is any different
than marjorie taylor green's on this
issue she just knows how to better frame
her answer
to be about her constituents and
election integrity
but she has no problem accepting maria
bartoromo's framing of the question so
check it out and understand that maria's
question is
do you think there will be a fair
election in 2022 which would allow you
to investigate the 2020 election
which was of course stolen it's a
ridiculous question and here's how elise
stefanik answers it
are you expecting a uh a free and fair
election to enable you to do that next
year
well that's one of the really important
issues maria when i go home to my
district and as i talk to my colleagues
this is the case across the country
voters want to make sure that they have
faith in our election system which is
why election integrity and election
security
is a top priority for the american
people and it should matter to you
whether you're republican democrat or
independent this is why you're seeing
state legislatures
like florida like arizona taking action
to address
and strengthen their election systems
this is why she's so slippery
that's right americans care about secure
election systems and we have them
the 2020 election was not close it was
one of the most secure that we've had
and as always with some anecdotal
instances of irregularities
not nearly a fraction of what you need
to change the results in any one state
it doesn't matter though because that's
not what elise stefanik will tell you
she'll tell you since it matters to my
constituents it was also irregular
we need major action what they mean by
this is we didn't suppress enough of the
vote in 2020.
if you look at her comments outside of
this interview since her election
since the election you get a sense for
her point of view
she's promoted conspiracy theories about
a stolen election hours after
the invasion of the capital on january
6th she voted against accepting
pennsylvania's electoral votes
on january 12th harvard university
announced they are removing stefanik
from its institute of politics
because of her role in promoting these
false claims
but she's better at talking about it to
sound marginally less off the wall
than some of her colleagues and that
makes her dangerous here's a little bit
more and then it sort of comes mask off
we need voter identification we need
chain of custody when it comes to the
absentee mail-in ballots
signature verifications and what the
democrats have put forward
is a federal takeover to put them into
power
forever the for the politicians act hr1
which would be taxpayer-funded campaigns
completely off the rails a sensible
reform
sensible reforms are radical far left
it's absolutely a crazy authoritarian
clampdown on voting which they want
republicans are talking about election
integrity but that's not really what
they want here
she's horrifying and then just for a
little more flavor
the interview ends with elise stefanik
talking about how great donald trump is
it's almost like a rite of passage on
maria bartoromo's show
yeah real quick congressman before you
go president trump supported you to get
the third highest rank
in the gop how important is he to the
party right now
he's critical to the party he is the
leader of the republican party
voters determine the leader of the
republican party and they continue to
look
to president trump for his vision and
he's going to be important part of us
winning back the house in 2022.
all right we will leave it there
congrats again congresswoman we hope
you'll come back we will be watching the
developments thank you so much
so there it is pledging full and total
loyalty to donald trump it's all his for
the taking
and as far as elise stefanik is
concerned trump gets to pick republican
winners in 2022
and trump gets to run in 2024 if he so
wants
and she will support him blindly
and to the ends of the earth this is the
republican party right now
cheney out that's what liz cheney was
replaced by
and if this tells us anything about the
next couple of years
it's that it doesn't seem the republican
party is going to be freeing itself
from the grip of trump send me your
thoughts if you disagree
you can find us on instagram at david
pakman show
find me on instagram at david.pacman
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough
time to read all the books you want to
read you have to check out one of my
favorite apps called
blinkist blinkist takes thousands of
popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book
or audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from 10
different books in an afternoon
obviously it's
perfect for exposing yourself to a new
book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25 percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video